alexandre de béchio journaliste bonsoir
alexandre ii vécurent merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france
les voisins européens on est un petit
peu jaloux un qui annonce une stratégie
de déconfinement en france on reste dans
le flou en musique ça va durer mais
enfin aucun mot en tout cas sur une
éventuelle stratégie de sortie quelle
est votre réaction comment vous vous
l'expliquer je pense qu'on peut
l'expliquer puisqu'on a bien compris que
pour des cons fine et il fallait avoir
les moyens nécessaires c'est à dire les
masques et les tests pour pouvoir
éventuellement isoler les personnes
malades les masques pour éviter la
diffusion du virus et comme l'état n'est
pas en capacité
voilà deux de fournir tout cela est
effectivement il parle trop tôt pour
parler de déconfinement mais on peut
s'interroger sur la stratégie qui
conduit à adopter
jean yves le drian disait spectacle on
l'attendait des masques commandés en
chine en juin
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas mettre en
place une stratégie de production à ce
qu'il aura pas fallu le faire avancer
des question qu'on peut se poser on peut
se demander si tous les moyens sont mis
en oeuvre pour que l'état puisse réagir
et fournir le matériel nécessaire à ce
fonctionnement et oui mais dans le même
temps olivier ferrand le ministre de la
santé nous dit tout simplement sur
l'épaule de porc de ces masques que la
question restait ouverte pour l'instant
il n'y a ni obligation ni même
recommandation en entendu le ministre de
la santé tout à l'heure oui je pense
qu'en en com comme depuis le début la
stratégie et la communication s'adapte à
la situation de pénurie je pense que là
on est toujours malheureusement dans
cette situation deux cas une pénurie du
coup olivier ans explique effectivement
il y en a pas d'obligation du match je
pense que si nous avions les masques a à
disposition il en serait peut-être bon
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron s'est rendu
en seine saint denis
et on l'a vu dans les rues d'ailleurs
bien entouré par les habitants la
remercier ces mêmes habitants qui
respecte le confinement et a été
interpellé d'ailleurs sur le manque
d'équipements pour les soignants ces
images justement qui ont circulé sur les
réseaux sociaux du président de la
république avec du monde lutiner autour
quel effet ça peut faire quand on
demande aux français de respecter
strictement le confinement est ce que
c'est une bonne communication la part du
président de la république selon vous
oui je pense qu'il ya une forme
d'incohérence dans cette communication
il y avait sans doute la volonté de
rappeler qu'il était le président de
tous les français y compris bien sûr de
territoire de la seine saint denis qui
est durement touchée par le corona des
routes mais je pense que l'effet va être
plutôt négatif puisque il a provoqué
autour de lui à un attroupement elle n'a
donc pas à montrer l'exemple du raca sec
chaud dans ce département qui a beaucoup
de casse parce qu'il ya aussi des zones
de non droit mais aussi parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de dettes soignante le
travailleuses des ehpad je suis pas sûr
qu elle avait besoin de ce signal là il
y apparaît comme un signal s'il a le
monde de de légèreté
et donc je crois que quand il va voir
lui-même les images les madjer à quoi il
va se rendre compte que l'opération de
communication risque hélas de se
retourner contre lui pour reparler de ce
déconfinement aujourd'hui
l'autriche a on l'a vu mais pas que
d'ailleurs l'italie l'autriche et
premier pays européen à annoncer cette
stratégie de déconfinement avec la
réouverture des magasins de certains
magasins au 14 avril autriche qui
affiche 204 morts sur 8 8 millions
d'habitants pourquoi s'en sort-il mieux
que nous ces autrichiens
je pense qu'au soutien à la solidité du
système de santé à l'anticipation la
capacité ou pas de produire des masses
par exemple également voient qu'il
peuvent en produire plusieurs centaines
de milliers voire plusieurs millions par
par semaine donc donc en fonction de ses
moyens là effectivement le le
déconfinement peut être envisagé
beaucoup plus rapidement hélas comme je
le disais tout à l'heure on est dans un
dans une gestion de la pénurie qui
révèle la faiblesse d'un système de
pensée de le penser par le chantait con
qu'on présentait comme comme extrêmement
fort en europe et qui se révèle
finalement beaucoup plus fragile avec un
suffisamment de l'ue de pitoa
suffisamment de deux respirateurs la
stratégie du confinement elle est mise
en place pour finalement il est allé la
vague et parce qu'on n'a pas forcément
les moyens d'accueillir trop de
casseroles en même temps dans les
services hospitaliers et donc tant qu'on
ne pas lui pas assez à ces défaillances
eh bien on en reste à cette stratégie
défensive d'autres pays ont pu déployer
une stratégie plus offensive mais parce
qu'ils avaient finalement une
organisation de l'état système de santé
instable de production industrielle plus
solides finalement clos de trop une
dernière question alexandre ii vecchio
vous êtes observateur et vidéos
de cette société française depuis
longtemps vous êtes journaliste vous
écrivez dans le figaro comment vous
percevez la réaction des français
justement par rapport à cette gestion de
la crise de la part du gouvernement
je pense que les français font preuve de
sérénité jours quoi qu'on en dise les
mesures de confinement sont plutôt
respectée par la majorité des français
il faut souligner aussi le le courage
des premières lignes
bien sûr des soignants mais aussi les
travailleurs des départs des
questionnaires d'une france invisible
dont on perçoit aujourd'hui l'utilité
les français ont conscience que il nous
faut pas verser peut-être en ce moment
dans les polémiques inutiles mais sans
doute on ventile de la mémoire et
nautile toutes les défaillances tous les
problèmes stratégiques auxquels la
france est confrontée et l'heure du
bilan sans doute s'en souviendra je
pense qu'il n'est pas souhaitable en
tous les cas que le confinement se
maintiennent trop longtemps ne serait ce
que par des conséquences économiques qui
pourraient être pires finalement que les
conséquences anitea d'où l'intérêt de
déployer le plus rapidement possible une
stratégie efficace et s'il faut en
passer par des réquisitions une forme de
planification pour produire très vite
des basques je pense qu'il faut le faire
qu'il faut maintenant sortir de cette
bureaucratie qui nous ralentit depuis le
début merci alexandre david ciot d'avoir
été en direct avec nous